я була здивована в якійсь мірі шокована
почалася все з однієї дівчинки артилери
збігає і в неї ця куртка десь по коліна
ходити на роботу до сьомого місяця
вагітності Вони телефонують кажуть Ми
хочемо до вас зайти ніколи так не кажіть
мені я якраз тоді повинна була стати
матір'ю не дуже красиво танцювала зараз
вона в аеробіці Я ще тоді так
здивувалася Я думаю неочікувано кліка не
повинна в армії отримувати чоловічу
спільну білоруську Розкажіть будь ласка
як так сталося Що Ну останні вибори
Верховної Ради були в 19-му році А
нещодавно ЦВК оголосили вас народними
депутатами насправді для мене це було
найбільшим неочікуванням і сюрпризом
2023 року
тому що Звичайно я була в списку
європейської солідарності коли були
позачергові вибори до Верховної Ради в
2019 році я займала 26 місце в списку
нашої політичної сили навіть жодних
планів таких не було
Перший дзвінок звичайно поступив від
Марини Анатоліївни це лідер нашої
політичної сили у Київській міській раді
Вона запропонувала зустрітися спільно з
Петром олексійовичем є ще тоді так
здивувалася думаю
неочікувано щось точно мене
точно буде якийсь сюрприз я була
здивована в якійсь мірі шокована тому що
я не думала що в цьому скликанні
вдасться попрацювати поруч з дуже
потужною командою в парламенті Тим паче
європейська Солідарність
працює досить багато
докладає нереальних зусиль до нашої
Перемоги до допомоги нашим збройним
силам України
до допомоги звичайним людям які цього
потребують тому для мене насправді це
величезна відповідальність особливо в
контексті того що
доєднуюсь я до цієї команди замість
Михайла забродського Це мабуть подвійна
відповідальність для мене Але сподіваюсь
що
я впораюсь ентузіазму вистачає сил
натхнення енергії
хороших правильних ідей також вистачає
над якими я планую працювати чомусь
назвали мої Джессіка пояснити Я це не
можу але вона вже якщо чесно
перекочувала у всіх локаціях Києва де ми
проводили івенти вона вже навіть була на
виставці волонтер Експо так що в
принципі
емоційних розладів в неї не буває
апатії вигоряння теж не буває
якщо вона у нас
надійна така
досягнення
переконатися мабуть нам потрібно Вийти
за межі цього штабу і пройтися
оболонським районом для того щоб я
показала конкретні речі до яких я була
залучена тому що це мої дві неповних
каденції перша каденція була з 2015 по
22-й рік ці 5 років Я працювала як член
постійної комісії з питань бюджету і
соціально-економічного розвитку в
Київській міській раді мабуть зараз не
буду перечисляти всі адреси всі
дошкільні навчальні заклади всі школи
стадіони сквери парки але мабуть на звук
знакові Мені досить приємно що я була
дотична в тому числі і до створення
парку Наталка
спільно з київським міським головою
Віталієм Кличко тому що він створювався
декілька років і власне це вже є
своєрідною перлиною і зразковим парком
не просто в оболонському районі а в
Києві досить багато киян з інших районів
приїздять сюди для того щоб провести час
тут з дітьми зайнятися спортом просто
прогулятися набережною і відчути
своєрідну енергетику мабуть Оболонського
району тому що кожен район столиці Він
має свою енергетику так само і в
оболонському районі моя гордість - це
дошкільний навчальний заклад
661 Він знаходиться на вулиці прирічній
це садочок який був в аварійному стані з
жодного разу з моменту коли його
побудували в ньому не проводились ніякі
роботи
моїм проектом Рішення було започатковано
проектування і реконструкцію цього
садочка це також є такий знаковий
садочок я дуже хотіла щоб всі комунальні
садки міста Києва виглядали Таким чином
я коли розпочинався
будівництво цього садочку і ми
зустрічалися з батьківським колективом Я
якраз тоді повинна була стати матір'ю а
вже через три роки ми разом з прийшли
туди для того щоб відкрити після
реконструкції цей дитячий садочок він
дуже класний в ньому є басейн всередині
це 14 оновлених груп з відповідним
благоустроєм кожної групи є своя ділянка
для прогулянки І взагалі там застосовані
екологічні матеріали ми над цим
працювали дуже багато і активно Я б дуже
хотіла щоб мій син відвідував цей
садочок Я завжди коли щось роблю я це
все приміряю на собі чи хотіла б я
відпочивати в такому парку чи хотіла б я
щоб моя дитина відвідувала дитячий
садочок чи хотіла б я щоб моя дитина
відвідувала ту чи іншу школу тому що я
робила досить великий акцент на сферу
освіти і сферу житлово-комунального
господарства тому що
в оболонському районі є багато будинків
які там побудовані в 70-х роках їхній
стан не зовсім хороший якщо ми кажемо
про інженерні мережі про Зони загального
фінансування дах який постійно протікає
підвальні приміщення зовсім не
пристосовані тому я працювала над тим
щоб
виділялися кошти і контролювала
виконання робіт по кожному із об'єктів
по кожному з будинків в минулому
скликанні всі будинки мого округу тоді
ще Маленького це 10-й мікрорайон в
кожному будинку ми замінили вікна ми
поремонтували інженерні мережі створили
біля будинків і між будинками декілька
скверів До речі трішки далі на прирічній
є класна алея яка виходить на проспект
Володимира Івасюка біля податкової
раніше це була просто Чорна така чорна
пітьма чорна алея на які люди в прямому
сенсі слова ламали собі ноги тому що там
були оці такі старі плити ми зробили
реконструкцію
там три дитячих майданчики зі
спортивними
ну виглядає класно виглядає достойно Я
пишаюся тими об'єктами які вдалося
зробити спільно з комунальними
підприємствами спільно з керівництвом
оболонської районної адміністрації
І власне я не полишаю цієї ідеї в
оболонському районі ще є над чим
працювати тут багато роботи які загалом
столиці тому якщо в мене буде можливість
я буду продовжувати
робити ті проекти які я запланувала в
мене ще в планах стадіон між школою 226
гімназією Оболонь
на проспекті Івасюка ще декілька
об'єктів які я передбачала в бюджеті на
цей рік це були мої депутатські запити в
кінці Минулого року вони були прийняті І
власне ці роботи будуть виконуватися
цього року тому контролювати я їх точно
буду Мені вже задавали одне питання
стосовно того чим власне Я буду
займатися в парламенті в першу чергу в
контексті того Чим я займаюся протягом
2022 року звичайно хотілось би зробити
акцент на реформі речового забезпечення
для жінок в Українській армії жінок
зараз у нас в Збройних силах України
орієнтовно 60 тисяч з них понад 5 тисяч
жінок несуть службу безпосередньо в зоні
бойових дій але це ми Зараз скажемо
тільки про збройні сили України але тут
потрібно розуміти що
українські жінки вони такі войовничі
сміливі дуже хоробрі вони насправді
несуть службу не тільки в Збройних силах
України вони так само є національній
Гвардії Державній прикордонній Службі в
різних дфтг в спецпідрозділах
національної поліції і якщо загалом
взяти всю кількість жінок які сьогодні
воюють поруч з чоловіками на рівних
засадах то це мабуть орієнтовно 1/5 і в
цьому контексті Мені дуже сподобалася
фраза Юлії паєвської тайри Вона сказала
що під
кожним п'ятим пікселем б'ється жіноче
серце і власне Ми намагаємося зі свого
боку їх дуже сильно підтримувати станом
на сьогодні ми до речі вже забезпечили
безкоштовно понад 3000 жінок які на
передовій несуть службу Я навіть 1 січня
2023 року
прокидаюся вранці беру телефон і бачу що
наші наша група із нашої команди Вона
просто переповнена повідомленнями Я
починаю їх читати а дівчата вже на Новій
по відправляють форми на передову Тобто
ми працюємо в режимі non-stop 24/7 не
зупиняємось тому що це досить така
багатофункціональна робота з однієї
сторони ми постійно шукаємо партнерства
Ми шукаємо компанії і людей які
допоможуть нам зібрати донати тому що ми
саме на ці кошти закуповуємо матеріал і
відчуваємо форми для наших захисниць з
іншого боку це комунікація самими
дівчатами тому що це не просто
отримали заявку опрацювали підібрали
форму і відправили її по Новій Пошті на
передову ні Ми весь час ведемо
комунікацію з дівчатами у кожної з них є
свої питання свої проблеми свої виклики
свій емоційний стан вони досить часто
буває приїздять не у відпустку а там на
поповнення матеріальних запасів чи на
ротацію буває таке що вони там на пів
дня приїжджають в Київ ввечері в них вже
Вони телефонують і кажуть Ми хочемо до
вас зайти і ми в неділю відкриваємо наш
штаб Сідаємо п'ємо тут каву чай
спілкуємося про їхні потреби про їхні
проблемні питання це знаєте це різні
дівчата тому що частина з них вже несла
службу у збройних силах України до
повномасштабного вторгнення
вони несли службу в АТО і звичайно
частина дівчат які після 24 лютого маючи
роботу маючи відповідний факт та
професію прийняли рішення Ось так
кардинально змінити своє життя і
приєднатися до лав збройних сил України
і таких дуже багато тому що кількість
жінок в лавах Збройних сил вона зростає
кожного дня з геометричною прогресією
якщо ми подивимося просто на порівняємо
наприклад В 2021 році в Збройних Силах
Було трішки більше ніж 30 тисяч зараз їх
вже 60 це не рахуючи дівчат які задіяні
також в
відповідних важливих завданнях в інших
силових структурах тому ми весь час з
ними на зв'язку навіть сьогодні вранці я
відкрила Instagram і просто
переписувалася з декількома дівчатами ми
вже домовляємо домовляємось про зустріч
сьогодні повинні приїхати 5 дівчат які
також на два дні в Києві підтримка їх
в будь-який спосіб не тільки забезпечити
їх формою і все Це для них дуже важливо
тому власне я не втомлююсь повторювати
що кожна жінка військовослужбовиця чи
кожна жінка ветеранка вона точно може
розраховувати на нашу команду на нашу
підтримку і на те що ми зі свого боку
зробимо все можливе і неможливо для того
щоб допомогти їм у вирішенні їхніх
питань у Костенко свою улюблену
ось Оксанка рубаняк зараз тут десь
відкритка має бути
тут
Ось вона а от розкажіть побільше про
проект
про сам проект
розкажіть про нього бо я бачив листа в
Instagram
в чому його ключова фішка коли ви
взагалі стартанули свою роботу до речі
цікаве запитання Я нещодавно також стала
свою стрічку в соцмережі ми хотіли
просто Нас запитали А коли ви розпочали
Я кажу Ну я дізналася про те що взагалі
немає жіночої форми в Українській армії
десь кінець квітня початок травня і
потім ми перевірили і перший пост який я
написала з закликом до того що ми хочемо
створити з нуля жіночу військову форму
Ми замовили екземпляри жіночої форми з
інших країн світу і розпочинаємо цю
активну роботу тому просимо нас
підтримати дата була 1 червня 2022 року
вперше першу партію в 300 комплектів ми
зробили в серпні і вже почали її
надавати дівчатам для того щоб
відтестувати отримати зворотній зв'язок
я розуміла що можливо прийдеться щось
доопрацювати ми часто питали Чи все
добре чуть кишені зручні Можливо щось
додати Можливо щось є лишнім і потім вже
десь з кінця вересня коли ми отримали
фідбек дівчата Скали Все ок Все зручно
штани сидять ідеально кітель зручний Ми
почали відшивати на постійній основі
станом до сьогодні І власне і до літа І
взагалі до кінця року мабуть будемо
відчувати і забезпечили Таким чином
понад 3000 жінок на цей рік у нас план
забезпечити 6 тисяч жінок
комплектами уніформи тому я тут власне
хочу подякувати користуючись нагодою
всім партнерам кожному українцю який
донатить кожного дня кошти іноземним
компаніям які самі звертаються до нас от
ми працюємо працюємо розуміємо що нам
потрібно зараз матеріалу закупити
декілька кілометрів
Щоб процес пошиву не зупиняти і в якийсь
момент нам пише ізраїльська іт-компанія
Каже ми хочемо задонатити вам кошти і
одягнути 200 дівчат
клас І так от відбувається якийсь таке
диво кожного дня тому що деякі Українки
які проживають за кордоном багато років
вони нам надсилають матеріал просто 2
тонни матеріалу ми його частково
відправляємо військовим вони там
використовують їх з частини матеріалів
ми можемо відчути штани або термобілизну
І от власне такі дива трапляються і за
рахунок них в нас є змога розвивати цей
проект ми хочемо
створити в Україні культуру коли всі
виробники будуть окрім чоловічої
амуніції створювати щось для жінок в
армії чому я так кажу бо коли в минулому
році я дізналася про цю проблему
[музика]
Я хотіла знайти для дівчинки яка
попросила в мене цю форму це була
дівчинка із артилерії з Харківського
напрямку хотіла знайти до неї цю форму І
передати Це просто почалося все з однієї
дівчинки артилеристки Я почала шукати
зрозуміла що в нас не те що жоден
виробник ніколи не відчував жіночу форму
в нас навіть немає представлених брендів
які б купували цю форму закордону
наприклад з Америки тому що в Америці
вони дуже прогресивні вони з 2009 року
почали розробляти жіночу форму а в
Україні навіть вона не представлена Ну
ви можете її на амазоні замовити але ви
її там дочекаєтеся з урахуванням того
періоду часу і логістики Ну так місяців
через три я була дуже здивована мені
навіть якось якщо чесно так як не
вкладалося сильно в голові чому
виробники які виконують державні
замовлення на рівні Міністерства оборони
жодного разу просто не створили щось для
жінок а роками дівчата отриму форму в
армії вони і перешивали причому якщо На
той період часу собівартість форми була
там десь до 1000 грн от Вони наймали
швею чекали там 10 днів і платили 2,500
грн що просто ця форма перешити і вона
все одно була незручна тому от така моя
глобальна велика ціль щоб навіть в
Україні створити цю культуру коли інші
виробники
будуть усвідомлювати що ну нас трішки
все змінилося в армії в нас багато жінок
в армії і цих жінок потрібно
забезпечувати з урахуванням їхніх потреб
а не просто забезпечили формули Головне
що вона піксельна і Окей чому вже 9
років іде війна і в нас досі не було
жіночої форми мені видається що так
історично склалося Тому що тільки в 2018
році До речі завдяки адвокації
членів команди європейської Солідарності
в парламенті Я знаю цим активно
займалася Марія Іонова Ірина Геращенко
був прийнятий закон про рівні права
чоловіків і жінок в армії із тих пір
тільки з 2018 року Уявіть собі дівчата в
Українській армії мають змогу займати ті
самі бойові позиції і посади що і
чоловіки тобто до 2018 року вже коли в
нас була війна
дівчата де-факто були артилеристками
виконували бойові завдання А де Юра за
документами вони були там секретарками
організаторами дозвілля
і так далі тобто не було вказано якою
бойовою спеціалізацією Вона володіє тому
що це було заборонено законодавчому
рівні після 2018-го жінки отримали шанс
будувати кар'єру в лавах ЗСУ
І власне Мені здається що ні в Збройних
в міністерстві оборони не були готові до
такої кількості жінок в армії цього
насправді ніхто не очікував а після
повного масштабного вторгнення коли ми
бачимо що просто жінки
за своїм власним бажанням Як доброволеці
в нас немає обов'язково ймобілізації як
в Ізраїлі вони просто беруть документи
ідуть у військкомати І стоять в черзі а
їм кажуть так Зачекай трішки Давай
пізніше ми зараз з чоловіками
розберемося а потім будемо ні от я чула
Реальні історії коли дівчата просто
домагалися того щоби
щоби їх взяли на контракт і вони поїхали
саме в зону бойових дій вони проходили
досить складні за навантаженням фізичні
тренування отримували певний рівень
навичок бойових
і досить багато з них вже понад рік
знаходяться там несуть службу Мені
здається з урахуванням цього цієї не
готовності
і було спричинено що немає форми хоча по
великому рахунку жінки в Українській
армії завжди були да їх було мало у 2008
році їх Було трішки більше ніж 1500 Але
з кожним роком ця кількість
збільшувалась збільшувалася і вже зараз
я бачу чітке розуміння чітке прийняття
того факту що необхідно змінювати
систему речового забезпечення необхідно
внести зміни в існуючи накази
Міністерства оборони і затвердити
стандарт жіночої військової форми Тільки
після цього Міністерство оборони зможе
робити державні замовлення цієї форми і
забезпечувати ним жінок це певний шлях
ми над цим працюємо ми в активній
комунікації з міністерством обороною
оборони
з представниками збройних сил України в
нас постійно відбувається робоча
зустрічі ми вдосконалюємо існуючі лекало
і навіть в листопаді 22-го року ми
передали комплекти форми і дві моделі
тактичної білизни для офіційного
експериментального тестування в
міністерстві оборони так вони вже
частково білизна вже від тестована
отримали просто колосальний фідбек від
дівчат про рівень зручності і комфорту
вона зараз в Франківщині лежить в
лікарні в неї три Осколки ось ніби
справи добре вона якраз буквально
Тиждень тому мені відписалася і
в мене якийсь аж полегшення відбулось
тому що дуже за неї переживала розкажіть
Де ми зараз от знаходимось з вами Це
мабуть такий невеличкий сортувальний наш
центр і міні-склад чому міні-склад Тому
що тут лише частина того одягу який ми
отримуємо і потім відразу відправляємо
добре що ви застали полиці які заповнені
одягом тому що зазвичай У нас вони тут
на половину пусті тому що все
Відбувається наступним чином ми
відчуваємо військовий одяг і інші
елементи амуніції для жінок
військовослужбовець в трьох регіонах це
Харків це Хмельницький та Хмельницька
область і івано-франківська область
Тобто це чинні виробники які багато
років відчувають одяг ми з ними уклали
договір і вони для нас відчувають ті
позиції які ми створили з нуля Ми з нуля
створили для них уніформу дуже зручну
комфортно і Що найголовніше
функціонально
потім ми почали працювати над іншими
елементами нашарування які власне
напряму впливають на ефективність
солдата чи офіцера я вам поясню чому
жінка не повинна в армії отримувати
чоловічу спільну білизну вона повинна
отримувати жіночу І власне Ми почали зі
створення
тактичної білизни
уніформи яка включає штани і кітель
термобілизни термобілизна вже двох типів
на більш холодну погоду і на міжсезоння
так як це передбачено в армії це певні
елементи нашарування які ви можете
використовувати в залежності від
погодніх умов і від типу завдань які ви
виконуєте Також ми створили зимовий одяг
звичайно зимові куртки чоловічі і жіночі
вони є універсальними але проблема
забезпеченням полягає в тому що
в зоні бойових дій дуже багато дівчат
таких тендітних кілограмів 40 42 і їм
видають при цьому розмір куртки 56 от
Уявіть собі дівчинка одягає і в неї ця
куртка десь по коліна я не уявляю собі
як можна в такій куртці одіти зверху
бронежилет А ще там не знаю рюкзак
парамедика і просто пробігти навіть
кілометр А ще зброя в куртці яка по
коліна ну тобто це в першу чергу знижує
максимально ефективність тому що коли
жінка виходить на бойове завдання вона
повинна думати про ефективність
виконання цього бойового завдання а не
про те що вона
вилітає з штанів Перепрошую або або щось
її давить тисне чи щось незручно тому ми
власне створюємо максимально
зручний одяг військовий який відповідає
в першу чергу жіноче тілобудові тому що
фізіологія чоловіки і жінок все ж таки
відрізняються це Ігнорувати не можна в
деяких арміях світу де кількість жінок в
армії є досить ни думаю у них
здебільшого це форма універсальна або
унісекс як її називають але в
Українській армії форма відшивається за
чоловічий розмірною сіткою це означає що
враховується широкий чоловічі плечі
ширша талія
штани відповідно також з іншої посадкою
тому що візуально ця форма не
відрізняється від чоловічої Але якщо ми
подивимося на лекало чоловіче і жіноче
то ми побачимо цю різницю що що це за
форма Так це форма яку ми розробили за
зразком американської натівської форми
для вагітних досить часто Люди дивуються
і кажуть як це вагітній що воюють Ну я
їм пояснюю вагітність звичайно не воюють
Вони знаходяться в штабах
частина - це можуть бути юристи діловоди
кадри фінансисти бухгалтери це можуть
бути і бойові спеціалізації Але звичайно
жінка вже не при виконанні бойового
завдання але трудове законодавство для
військових і циві воно однакове і за
статутом жінка повинна ходити на роботу
до сьомого місяця вагітності в статутній
військовій формі Ну мені трошки складно
уявити як можна на 7 місяці вагітності
ходити в формі яка не передбачена
конкретно для вагітних от станом на 2021
рік в Збройних силах України було більше
ніж 2 000 вагітних Ну от Уявіть собі
2000 жінок а форми для вагітних В них
немає Я пам'ятаю
ще тоді в 2016 році урсула фонделяйн яка
займала посаду міністрики оборони
Німеччини заявила про те що вони також
почали розробляти форму для вагітних І
взагалі дуже багатьох країнах світу і
передбачена форма для вагітних
військовослужбовців Ось так вона
виглядає Це просто великий розмір але
він передбачає цілковиту зручність і
Комфорт для того щоб навіть до 9 місяця
Якщо необхідно
одягати Ось такі діти тут позаду є
додаткова фіксація в залежності від
місяця вагітності можна зафіксувати
кітель так Як зручно
це тестовий екземпляр який ми відшили
наша робота Відбувається наступним чином
ми розробляємо лекало відчуваємо
тестовий зразок якщо тестовий зразок Ок
І в нас немає зауважень ми розробляємо
градацію по розмірах
розробляємо лекало
по всім розмірам Я маю на увазі і
надсилаємо на виробництво позаду вас
шеврони стіна з шевронами які нам також
дівчата своїх частин передають Так що ми
вже і їх почали колекціонувати це
подарунки прямо відірвані від серця тому
що деяких шевронів є тільки два
екземпляри все більше їх немає це якісь
такі унікальні особисті речі які дівчата
нам віддають може є якісь цікаві історії
які ми ділили з вами дівчата які б ви
могли розказати
перше
лист очікування на форми згідно з яких
ми отримали запити від дівчат станом на
зараз вже понад 4000 це тільки лист
очікування тобто дівчат дуже багато
Ми назвали цю стіну стіна незламності
тому що кожна дівчина Це мабуть тільки
два відсотки дівчат які тут зображені на
фотографіях але кожна з тих яка тут і
фотографії якої тут немає але вона є на
нашій сторінці в соціальній мережі у
кожної якась унікальна життєва Історія є
трагічні історії тому що багато дівчат
пішли на фронт
після того як втратили своїх чоловіків
або коханих і Вони приймали таке рішення
свідомо іти воювати
є дівчата які
які просто пішли на передову тому що
хтось із їхніх братів або батьків
знаходиться несе службу в армії і вони
також хочуть долучитися є просто цілі
сім'ї які несуть службу це і Батько і
мати і по двоє-троє дітей і всі вони
несуть офіційну службу в лавах Збройних
Сил України
дуже багато До речі дівчат
які ми не дивують навіть досі до 24
числа є дівчинка яка була танцівницею
професійної і хореограмом постановником
дуже красиво танцювала
Така тендітна балерина
зараз вона в аеророзвідці вже більше
року вона навіть не приїжджала у
відпустку і на ротацію не їздила то дуже
багато таких
глибоких дуже творчих
дуже таких незламних дівчат які
які роблять дуже складну роботу вона
емоційно складна Вона вимагає
і фізичних зусиль і моральних і
ментальних і от силу духу яку вони
показують насправді викликає в мене
цілковитий захват тому я пишаюся
знайомством з кожною з дівчат і
сподіваюсь що коли закінчиться війна і
ми переможемо
я точно організую в Києві захід куди
запрошую всі всі в дівчат яких Ми
одягнули в комплекті жіночий уніформи
від армбу іменал ми будемо мабуть багато
сміятися говорити і танцювати А щоб ви
зараз сказали дівчатам які знаходяться в
силах оборони Я мабуть
[музика]
скажу їм все те що я завжди їм кажу
перше дівчата Бережіть себе це знаєте
одна дівчинка навіть сказала
відповіла на це
ніколи так не кажіть мені
тому що ви повинні вірити в мене ви
повинні бути впевнені в тому що зі мною
буде все гаразд і ви не маєте взагалі ні
на крихту сумніватися в тому що так воно
і буде І я після цих слів я так
задумалася
і погодилася з нею справді так і є Ми
повинні вірити в них
я повторюся але я кожною з цих дівчат
захоплююсь я пишаюсь тим що в Україні є
такі войовничі жінки я їх називаю
войовничими амазонками і мені здається
що кожна українська жінка яка зі зброєю
в руках або яка в тилу працює і
допомагає вона захоплює весь світ
точно в світі дивляться на наших жінок і
[музика]
Я навіть знаю людей які спеціально
хочуть приїхати з ними познайомитися
тому що вони собі навіть уявити не могли
що Ось так от дівчина з
життя до 24 лютого 22-го року маючи
роботу маючи сім'ю і навіть маючи дітей
приймає рішення і йде на передову і я
знаю дівчат у котрих є діти
вони вивезли їх за кордон для того щоб
вони були в безпеці а самі вони на
передовій ну це це не може не
захоплювати